- (laughing) Oh, my gosh, Jaco.
Jaco and Jessi win!
Okay, we're back with Jenna Bush Hager
and Barbara Bush, everybody!
(audience cheering)
Their new book is once again called
The Superpower Sisterhood.
And since we're all children of the 1980s,
we thought that we would play game,
sisters versus sisters,
called Totally Rad 80's Trivia.
(energetic rock music plays)
♪ Totally Rad ♪
♪ 80's Trivia ♪
- [Kelly] Get it Jessi!
Who's also my soul
sister, my musical sister!
And my real sister isn't in town,
so will you be my sister today?
- [Jessi] I will be your sister.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Barbara & Jenna] Yay!
(audience cheers)
- [Jessi] Thank you.
- We are here and, you
can come right here ma'am.
You look so great in the eighties.
- [Jenna] You look so cute!
- [Jessi] Thank you!
(Kelly laughs)
Hi!
- [Jenna] Hi! Nice to meet you.
- [Jessi] Nice to meet you too.
- [Kelly] We are here
at our recently renamed,
- [Barbara] Hi!
- [Jessi] How are you?
- [Kelly] Nick Jonas
Lectern of Integrity.
He took over Nick Offerman's
and now we just need a host.
So Lord, I'm looking at you.
- [Lord] Hey Kelly. I'm, I'm a Taurus too.
How about that?
- [Kelly] Yeah! Yes!
- [Lord] Isn't that amazing?
- [Kelly] Everyone awesome is.
- [Lord] That's right.
Now, it's nice to see you
as well Barbara and Jenna.
Now nice to see you.
- Is that God?
- [Lord] Don't mess with Texas
- [Kelly] It's God.
- [Lord] It is. It is.
The one and only.
The one and only
- We have the direct line.
- [Lord] Okay, here's how this game works.
I'm gonna ask a question about
pop culture of the 1980s.
Now, if you know the answer,
you're gonna hit your button.
Now you can hit the button
before I'm done talking,
but then you're gonna miss my sultry voice
so I don't recommend it
- Okay, waiting 'til he's done.
- [Lord] Also, steals are allowed.
You can steal.
- Okay.
- [Lord] Now if Jenna and Barbara win,
their photos will be
added to the Blake Shelton
Wall of Champions who beat Kelly Clarkson.
- What?
- [Kelly] We hate that wall.
We hate that wall.
- [Lord] Oh I love when that happens.
- [Jessi] It's not gonna happen.
- It's a dumb wall.
- [Barbara] We're gonna be
on that wall.
- [Jenna] Barbara, come on!
We can't lose this.
- We're goin' on that wall.
- I feel good.
- [Lord] Okay.
Here we go. Now.
- I'm nervous.
- [Jessi] I know me too.
I'm sweatin' a little bit.
- [Lord] Here's your first question.
- Okay.
- [Lord] What line of plush dolls
would stare down the bad guys
as beams of light and rainbows
shot out of their bellies.
- Care bears.
(ding)
- [Lord] It is care bears!
- [Jenna] No!
- I thought beanie babies at first.
- Nope, he said second,
the second he said stare I was like,
- Oh stare! Oh stare!
- [Lord] Here's the next one!
What Oscar winning actress
released her first workout video in 1982.
- I had her on here! I had her on here!
Jane Fonda! Jane Fonda!
(ding)
- [Lord] It is Jane Fonda.
- I was like, I was
like, what is her name?
What is her name?
- Is our thing turned off?
What is happening?
- This is not on.
Our button doesn't work.
- [Lord] Don't start with me.
Don't start with me.
- [Jessi] Do you love it?
- No, we don't.
- [Barbara] We don't actually.
- Remember we're 2-0! This is not cool!
- [Barbara] Okay, I feel
like our button's broken.
- Our button is broken!
- [Lord] All right, here we go.
All right, now let's get, chill now.
Get your leg warmers on
and let's do our next one.
- Yeah! Get physical!
- [Lord] Here we go.
Here's your next question.
- Okay.
- [Lord] According to the
band, Tommy Tutone in 1981,
What was Jenny's phone number?
- 8 6 7 5 3 0 9.
- It was 8 6 7 5 3 0 9.
(ding)
- I told you she was good at math!
♪ 8 6 7 5 3 0 9 ♪
- We are so late, we're musicians!
- I know!
- [Lord] Yeah that's a shame.
- Am I good at math?
Or am I good at math?
(Kelly laughs)
- She's good with numbers.
- This is why I brought my sissy!
- [Jessi] 8 6 7 5 3 0 9.
- [Lord] Yeah, don't, don't sing anymore.
Don't sing anymore. It'll
cost us a million dollars.
(Kelly laughs)
Okay?
Now here we go.
Now, Kelly and Jessi,
you're still in the lead.
You got two points.
Jenna and Barbara, you got one point.
Come on now! You can do this!
- Come on now!
- Thank you!
- [Lord] Here's your next question.
Here you go.
Who was the first woman to be inducted
into the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame in 1987,
finally earning a little R-E-S-P-E-C-T?
- [Kelly] Ah! Oh I hit it!
I feel like I hit it!
- Aretha Franklin!
- Franklin!
(ding)
- [Lord] It was
Aretha Franklin.
♪ R E S P E C T ♪
♪ Find out what it means to me ♪
Now we got ourselves a tie.
That's what I'm talkin' about.
- Okay.
- Need to make sure this thing's still,
- [Jenna] No, believe
me, I know what you mean.
- [Barbara] No, we
already went through that.
- Just needed to make sure that worked.
- [Lord] Yeah, it's still workin'.
It's still workin'.
- Dammit, you're quick.
(air horn blows)
- We missed the two music things!
- What does that noise mean?
- [Lord] This is it.
You're final question.
- Double or nothing? Oh, our last one?
- Final countdown! Which
you can't afford either.
- [Lord] And this is for double,
this is for double the points.
This is for double the points now.
- Okay.
- Double the points.
- [Lord] So pay close attention.
- Think fast. Fast.
- [Lord] The 1981 Queen and
Bowie song, Under Pressure,
was sampled,
- No! No! You have to stop! Right?
- Yep!
- The, Under Pressure was sampled
- [Lord] By?
- By Vanilla Ice,
who did Ice Ice Baby.
(ding)
- Oh my god!
- [Lord] You have done it!
(air horns blows)
What a surprise!
- Oh my god!
- [Lord] What a shock to no one.
- What?
What?
- You just, you were not,
you left.
- I wasn't here!
- You left!
- I left!
I was like, help me!
'Cause I thought you were
done and you weren't.
- Wait! Is that it?
- Yep!
- But we're not done!
- You don't get on the wall!
- [Barbara] We what?
- [Kelly] Good game, ladies!
- Good game!
- Good game.
- [Kelly] All right,
Barbara and Jenna's new book
is called The Superpower
Sisterhood. Go get it.